in deutschland gibt es seit jahren nur
ein thema es geht um einwanderung
integration und obergrenzen sie wissen
wovon ich rede
der wolf dazu schaue ich nicht nur im
bundestag vorbei sondern treffe auch
wolfs befürworter gegner und betroffene
und wollte endlich mal ein wichtiges
thema der wolf wird gerade debattiert ja
kriegen sie das nicht wird das würde
jetzt gern ins kino
es geht zum thema wölfe auch haben sie
da keine zeit für wollen sie den wolf
jagen weil sie frau merkel nicht kriegen
beim thema wolf leidenschaftslos muss
ich sagen also ich bin also fisch wege
da ja das erste hilfe doch zum glück
gibt es auch noch politiker mit echten
lösungsansätzen
ob der wolf wirklich das große problem
ist weil wir haben lösungen jenseits des
abschusses ja zum beispiel könnte man
ihn auch als diesel tester bei vw
einsetzen ja ich glaube vw muss keinen
diesel mehr testen die wii ist schon
ganz genau was der diesel angerichtet
weil sie das problem sind die jungen und
begleiteten wölfe das wissen sie genau
was mir die erstmal groß werden und dann
schauen wir mal
weil wenn man nach rotkäppchen geht wer
der wolf ja auch ein gutes rezept gegen
altersarmut zb der könnte man auch sagen
ach die wölfe muss man zum abschuss
freigegeben wichtig ist aber ich glaube
was ganz anderes gehört ja dann muss der
kollege noch dazulernen und dann wurde
es nochmal richtig emotional
warum wollen sie die wölfe abschließen
wir haben ganz viele risse und alles
würde ich klar es gibt riss gutachter
und anderes mehr
die grünen sagen dann immer man muss man
muss sich darum kümmern dass man die
tierische und wer soll das bezahlen es
kann doch nicht sein dass wir von den
indern und in afrikanern verlangen dass
die löwen und tiger schützen
wir wollen ihn sei völlig aus cotton
bevor sie sich prügeln ich bin neutral
wollte ich nur kurz sagen weiter
sie sich doch mal dass endlich meine art
nach deutschland wieder einwandert dass
wir unsere fauna bereichert wird dadurch
aber über einwanderung und anderes essen
tätig ist nämlich geldproblemen das ist
um einwanderung die jamaika in den
appell jetzt geht's nach brandenburg wo
mehr wölfe leben als spd wähler
obwohl das gilt inzwischen auch für nrw
sie sind also gegen den wolf wir müssen
gegen den wolf sein der frist unsere
kelber der frist unsere schafe und jeder
der eine vernünftige ökologische
landwirtschaft betreibt der will
natürlich tiere auf der weide halten und
der wolf macht es unmöglich aber haben
sie schon mal am gegessen
natürlich habe ich mal haben dem wolf
werfen sie es vor gut obwohl das alles
verschlingende monster-trucks ein gutes
gefühl
oder doch eher laktose-intoleranz männer
sie fressen tatsächlich auch walnüsse
waldbeeren was im prinzip alles kann man
guter salat auch dabei sein
nach außen wieder salat dabei sein genau
wie damals
wenn sie dem wolf vegane lebensweise
beibringen ja dann kommen wir ins
geschäft ja aber wir als menschen wollen
natürlich essen und wir wollen das
fleisch auf eine naturnahe weise
produzieren und dafür brauchen wir
kinder wenn der wolf veganer wäre wären
idiot ja und deshalb bin ich auch kein
veganer so einfach ist es die wölfe
gesehen
die herde war unruhig ist er war
hinterher gefahren und hat den wolf
gesehen hatten aber nicht bekommen
sie haben eine richtige verfolgungsjagd
aufgenommen ob ich warum wollt meiner
herde beschützen und schießen darf man
sich nicht so wie man sonst mal ne
überfahren schon beeindruckenden tiere
muss ich sagen
die schöne tieren ja
[Musik]
berlin geprüft wenn sie verbaut worden
was für ein emotionaler tag im blut und
habe ich auch gesagt
stellen sie sich vor ich wäre jetzt der
wolf und dann können sie mir einfach mal
persönlich sagen was sie fühlen
ich bin ein toller typ aber hab ja ich
will hier nicht sehen
das werde ich bei den anderen parteien
auch immer von daher passt doch ein ganz
normaler dreh und damit zurück ins
studio
[Applaus]